are you spending more time monitoring
your services than developing new ones
find out how you can use anthos to
improve the observability of your
services and become more productive I'm
Brianna and welcome to you and those 101
software is revolutionizing every
industry it doesn't matter if your
company sells tires delivers pizza is a
bank or health recruit new employees
software is now a key part of what you
deliver so let's look at how you can use
and those to be productive while keeping
your customers happy and those gives you
access to a service operations dashboard
that greatly simplifies what it takes
for you to keep your applications up and
running at peak efficiency to serve
those wonderful customers of yours key
to making this happen
or what we call golden signals if you
can only measure four metrics of your
user facing systems focus on first
latency which is the time it takes to
service a request it's important to
distinguish between the latency of
successful requests and the latency of
failed requests second is traffic which
is the measure of how much demand is
being placed on your system measured in
high level system specific metrics third
is errors which are the rate of requests
that fail either explicitly for example
HTTP 500s implicitly example HTTP 200
success responses quite coupled with the
wrong content or by policy example if
you committed to one second response
times any request over one second is an
error and fourth saturation which is how
full your services a measure of your
system fraction emphasizing the
resources that are most constrained
these golden signals are the cornerstone
of stablishing and embracing sre best
practices at your organization if you're
looking into adopting these
methodologies the service mesh should be
your solution so what is the service
mesh a service mesh provides a
transparent and
language-independent way to flexibly and
easily automate application network
functions and it is a foundational
component of anthers anthem service mesh
helps you monitor and manage service
interactions across all your different
environments adopting micro services has
lots of benefits like increasing
velocity and scaling but it also adds
complexity if different teams own each
of these components how do you track the
total latency for that transaction or
ensure that traffic between these
services is secure as an operator you
have a tough job to do in order to give
your customers the amazing experience
they deserve and those service Mash
brings to you a topology view of all the
services deployed in the mesh you can
see what's running who calls home and
metrics for each interaction and the
service mesh generates these metrics
without any changes to your application
by tracking all communications between
your services on a single screen it
becomes easy for you as an administrator
to spot problems and see metrics
including all four of the golden signals
we talked about but also you can go as
steep as needed with detailed
information at the per node level
including CPU and memory usage these
metrics help your app developers as they
look to do performance tuning for the
services they own this is very useful to
us
operators too and those service Mash
lets you set service level objectives
against any of these generative metrics
we talked about and once you set up this
SLO you can immediately see how the
service is performing and once you have
a Salone you can start managing your
deployment risk using error budgets this
enables you to catch problems early and
fix them well before your customers run
into them what makes this so powerful is
that now you can break down the problem
of keeping your deployment running into
smaller more manageable pieces reducing
operational
complexity Aldo service mesh also
gathers all logs and traces for your
services bringing them together into one
place generally you might have one
system for metrics one system for logs
and something else for tracing so
correlating between them is difficult or
impossible
and those helps you bring them all
together there you have it with anthos
you can adopt sre best practices and
improve your observability using golden
signals try Antos service mesh and the
observability dashboard following the
links below and for more anthos content
don't forget to subscribe and check out
the entire and those 101 playlist
[Music]